we've got some new tv to talk about drew
barrymore is wrapping up her first week
as a talk show host
and she got fall tv star gabrielle union
to confirm a bring it on sequel
is it true it's true oh
my god i'm so excited
my my daughters are going to freak out
[Applause]
gabrielle still has that cheer uniform
she rocked it last halloween
but on monday gabby's got a different
kind of uniform when ellie's finest
premieres on fox
she plays a detective alongside jessica
alba in this bad boy spin-off that
originally made its debut on spectrum
you weren't here we got a behind the
scenes look at the ladies at work
as for how the cast spends their time
between tapes
[Music]
we get such a big kick out of justin and
her family doing their tick tocks and
and we tried to learn the dances we suck
we're not as talented
uh but we try to make it fun and come up
with different things
to entertain ourselves
ash is so mad he's not into it
it's literally like it's because he lost
a bet
or i let him play virtual golf for four
hours straight
and there's more fun strong women coming
to tv
looking good today sarah paulson sharon
stone and cynthia
nixon make crazy look so good in ryan
murphy's ratchet
streaming now on netflix think of it
kind of like
american horror story cuckoo's nest
since it tells the origin story of the
sadistic nurse
in the oscar-winning film do you wanna
have
fun it's a signature of ryan murphy that
his characters always go to
the craziest of darkest weirdest places
where do you go to get
okay there don't want to know
i am on your side it's this kind of
magical
uh inexplicable bizarro thing that i
wish i had the words to describe
american horror story star finn whitrock
who plays one of nurse ratchet's
psychiatric patients says
sarah was always the most prepared cast
member on set
she's like a razor blade she keeps you
on your toes but she's also
so in control she led the ship you know
and i was so glad we had her as our
as our captain